The recent arrival of the long-awaited
"Spider-Man: No Way Home" was thrilling for many
reasons, but the promise of seeing more than one
of Spidey's biggest foes join the Marvel Cinematic
Universe for the first time arguably had fans
more excited than any other aspect of its release.
Ever since Alfred Molina revealed that
he was reprising the role of Doc Ock,
a character he first portrayed in
Sam Raimi's "Spider-Man 2" in 2004,
franchise devotees began to eagerly
anticipate the chance to see he and
various villains from the other "Spider-Man"
films take on Tom Holland's Peter Parker.
Jaime Foxx's Electro is one of the
antagonists from a prior "Spider-Man" movie
who made their MCU debut in "No Way Home." Electro
first appeared on the big screen in
2014's "The Amazing Spider-Man 2."
Though the film is considered one of the worst to
star the famed web-slinger, Electro was certainly
a memorable villain, making his reintroduction in
the latest "Spider-Man" film a welcome inclusion,
in spite of the poor reception of
his first film appearance. That said,
the actor recently revealed that he initially
felt hesitant to reprise the role prior to
accepting — and would only return if one
condition in particular was met first.
MCU architect Kevin Feige and Sony producer
Amy Pascal recently sat down with Brandon
Davis from Comicbook.com, and amidst a discussion
of various other topics related to "Spider-Man:
No Way Home," the trio eventually
got to talking about Electro.
When the character first appeared in "The
Amazing Spider-Man 2," many fans were upset
by the character's full body-spanning electric
blue color, which was a far cry from his look in
the comics. However, trailers for "Spider-Man:
No Way Home" revealed that in his latest film,
Electro would be outfitted in a costume much
more akin to how the character appeared in
his comic book source material — a costume
which also features an Iron Man arc reactor.
This subject came up when Davis asked Feige if
Electro lost his blue appearance because of that
arc reactor. Feige, a veteran when it comes
to avoiding spoiling his own movies, replied,
"I won't say that you're wrong. I
also won't say that you're right."
He did share, however, that the studios promised
Foxx that Electro wouldn't be blue this time
around. Foxx himself has publicly shared his
distaste for the blue costume. Speaking at
the CCXP panel, he expressed his enthusiasm
for the new take on the character in the MCU,
saying he was "excited" for the change.
Electro is one of the more
sympathetic "Spider-Man" villains,
and the comic-accurate revision
to his appearance in "No Way Home"
indicates Marvel's commitment to bringing
this character to life the right way.
Following the release of "Spider-Man:
No Way Home" on December 17,
Jamie Foxx further discussed returning to
the role of Electro in an interview published
on the official Marvel website. After Foxx
reiterated that the promise of the character
sporting a new appearance contributed to him
accepting the role, he went on to explain
how Electro's acknowledgement of his new
look in the movie's script was integral to
pulling off such a drastic alteration to his
previously established character. Foxx said,
"The [biggest] thing that changed is
that he acknowledged the way he looked.
He acknowledged, 'Oh, I like this, I dig this.'
By doing that, it answers any questions like
why or what's this thing? Being able to do
that, and just bringing a little of the way
I wanted to talk and how I wanted to present
myself, [Electro] has a little hipness to him."
Foxx had further kind things to say about
his character's new look in response to
a question about the fact that his updated
costume resembles an electrician's uniform:
"It's electrician-chic. What I'm saying is that
it's fly. It's not a cape or anything like that.
I really dug that. That's cool
because it keeps it practical.
'Practical magic' is what you could
call it, because he's so practical."
So, while he appears to have disliked the look
of the character the first time around, Foxx
offered nothing but praise for both the process
through which the character was redesigned,
and the appearance they ultimately landed
on during the production of "No Way Home."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about "No Way Home"
are coming soon. Subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a single one.